ta décision d'appeler les deux
prochaines semaines seront décisives
quant à l'avenir de la loi sur la
laïcité de l'État la loi 21 à quelques
minutes du début des audiences en cours
d'appel de fervents opposants sont venus
réitérer leur opposition à la loi cette
loi a démontré qu'à leur actuelle les
minorités dans ce pays n'ont
effectivement
porte de droite le dossier est allé
jusqu'en cours d'appel parce qu'en avril
2021 un jugement de la Cour supérieure à
maintenu en bonne partie la loi sauf
pour les commissions scolaires
anglophones et les élus de l'Assemblée
nationale pour certains la décision du
juge Marc-André Blanchard va trop loin
et pour d'autres et les trop timides le
gouvernement du Québec la portée en
appel c'est sûr que ça plaît pas tout le
monde des défenseurs de la loi 21 comme
le Mouvement laïque québécois aimerait
que l'interdiction du port de signe
religieux s'applique sans exception à
certains employés du gouvernement dans
l'exercice de leur fonction
comme les enseignants au public l'école
n'est pas là pour assurer l'exercice
de la liberté de religion des
enseignants et là pour protéger la
liberté de conscience des élèves alors
c'est ça de la loi 21 alors que c'est
des tracteurs estiment qu'elles
contrevient aux droits et libertés ce
sont les femmes visiblement musulmanes
qui sont disproportionnellement affectés
par la loi je veux dire il y a tellement
de femmes qui sont qui sont compétentes
qui sont humaines et déplorables en plus
dans un contexte de pénurie l'enseignant
quoi qu'il en soit tout porte à croire
que la décision de la Cour d'appel du
Québec ne sera qu'une formalité tous
s'attendent à ce que l'affaire se
retrouve devant la Cour suprême du
Canada c'est une bonne question nous
sommes prêtes à aller jusqu'à la Cour
suprême et à continuer cette lutte
absolument derrière les débats sur la
validité de la loi 21 sans cache un
autre celui du recours par les
gouvernements provinciaux de la
disposition de dérogation pour se
soustraire à d'éventuelles recours
devant les tribunaux le gouvernement du
Québec a déjà procédé de la sorte avec
l'adoption ou des projets de loi 21 et
96 la loi sur la Charte de la langue
française
ici Gabriel prout Radio-Canada Montréal